[Musique]
au plan économique aujourd'hui on marche
sur la tête
90 % de nos marchés sont ouverts à tous
les pays du monde
alors qu'en chine 0 % des marchés ne
l'est ce déséquilibre est inacceptable
et doit stopper
l'objectif c'est le soutien de nos pme
la préservation des savoir-faire rare
des savoir faire d'excellence
[Musique]
la règle de la préférence européenne et
française doit être appliquée
[Musique]
nos marchés doivent être réservés en
priorité à nos entreprises à nos pme en
europe et en france
[Musique]
l'avenir de l'europe comme celui de la
france passe par le soutien du
développement de nos pme
[Musique]
parce qu'il faut des députés européens
compétents pour l'europe et pour la
france
je voterai le 26 mai prochain dans le
cadre des élections européennes pour les
républicains
[Musique]